aymeric chan secrétaire général du
syndicat des mareyeurs boulonnais
bonsoir américiane merci de répondre à
nos questions ce soir aux assises de la
pêche et de la mer le week end mais
certains ont dénoncé le site le naufrage
de la france et de l'union européenne
vous avez le sentiment d'être pris entre
les filets d'une crise politique et
diplomatique qui vous dépasse
pas tout à créer alors effectivement aux
assises de la pêche et quelques annonces
qui était particulièrement malvenue a
notamment ses histoires de hand sortie
de flotte et heureusement heureusement
madame la ministre est venu assurer les
marins pêcheurs assurer l'ensemble de la
filière dimanche dernier à
boulogne-sur-mer en indiquant qu
effectivement le plan de sortie de
flotte était uniquement un outil parmi
d'autres et qui pourra éventuellement
être utilisé pour les quelques les
quelques bateaux qu'ils n'obtiendraient
pas game cause en matière de licence
mais rim os a été lâché dès est vraiment
rassuré quand même est-ce que c'est pas
un rétropédalage joue tellement
partiellement rassurés et bon
effectivement un certain nombre d'
annonces ont été faites un certain
nombre de procédures sont lancées
obtenir maintenant très rapidement les
quelques dizaines de licence qui nous
manque un sur le littoral de france et
une trentaine de licences et dans la
région c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement important puisque si vous
regardez un petit peu le positionnement
géographique on est située juste en face
du royaume uni et la manche est partagée
pour moitié du côté britannique et du
côté français donc nos nos pêcheries
sont effectivement extrêmement exposées
et le mareyage que je représente qui est
la première place en france pour pour le
mariage est extrêmement dépendante à la
fois des apports de pêche britanniques
mais également
des produits de la pêche de nos
flottille dans les eaux britanniques
donc il est indispensable que l'on
puisse mettre un peu plus la pression
pour que l'on sorte enfin de ce dossier
justement mettre un peu plus la pression
ça veut dire quoi annick girardin
emmanuel macron promettent de continuer
le combat
selon vous le gouvernement français fait
il réellement de son mieux est ce qu'il
ya un langage de communication qu'elle
marche de manoeuvre paris dispose selon
vous pour faire plier londres il ya un
certain nombre de mesures qui ont été
qui ont été annoncées de manière
relativement imprécise bon jusqu'à
présent la pression s'est fait
relativement discrète aurions nous dira
un même si une dizaine de licences été
obtenus depuis les annonces ou les
promesses de rétorsion là je pense que
manifestement les uns et les autres vont
passer à la vitesse supérieure autre
élément important c'est que l'europe est
rentré dans le jeu je pense que c'est un
élément essentiel
il fallait pas rester isolé face royaume
uni il est important que l'union
européenne soit au côté la france de sa
filière pour pouvoir faire la pression
sur eux sur les britanniques il faut pas
oublier que les britanniques sont gros
producteur un son gros pêcheurs mais
sont très peu consommateurs dont ils ont
absolument besoin
du marché européen et en particulier du
marché français qui consommait
énormément de produits de la mer alors
ce qui va être délicat c'est
effectivement de pouvoir augmenter le
niveau de pression sur sur le royaume
uni tout en préservant notre notre
activité 1 sur boulogne-sur-mer qui est
la première place de marché en france
pour les produits de la mer bon ben ya
un certain nombre de choses qui ont été
évoqués ils vont sans doute se mettre en
place la très très prochainement et je
vous espérez que les uns comme les
autres seront très rapidement recouvrer
la raison pour qu'on sorte enfin de ce
dossier qui n'a que trop duré puisque
l'ensemble de ces licences devait être
accordée depuis la fin janvier voire le
début février ça fait quand même un an
que ça dure et concrètement sur le
terrain ça se traduit comment au niveau
des têtes quels sont les états d'esprit
de vos confrères est-ce qu'ils souffrent
également ce qui en a qui pourraient
déposer le bilan ce que les
professionnels de la filière française
ont des fins de mois plus difficiles
en matière en matière de pêcheurs où il
ya des situations qui sont qui sont
extrêmement délicat en ce qui concerne
l'aval de la filière et et les mareyeurs
ça dépend un petit peu du positionnement
de la spécialité de l'entreprise mais on
a quand même subi
des arrêts des arrêts temporaires de nos
bateaux si vous voulez quand vous avez
la moitié de vos qui vous est finalement
interdit à vous êtes obligés de gérer
les quotas de gérer la pression de pêche
et nous avons depuis le début de l'année
bas des arrêts des bateaux par
intermittence et quand votre métier et
travail et du poisson et qu'on rapporte
moins de poissons forcément ça pose un
problème alors on est on est sur des
baisses d'activité pour les entreprises
les plus touchées qui sont de l'ordre de
20% et d'un pour cent c'est quelque
chose qui est extrêmement à part ça ne
peut pas durer il faut absolument qu'on
puisse recouvrer une situation normale
merci beaucoup aimeraient kachan d'avoir
répondu à nos questions de nous avoir
éclairé sur votre situation je rappelle
que vous êtes le secrétaire général du
syndicat des mareyeurs boulonnais